right we're still in complex number land
I won't talk about all of the obvious
things most of you will find getting the
argument one mark there on part two you
had to show me some working before you
got to negative 64 I think most of you
recognize that but I was surprised of a
small number did not and they just their
new it is not hard to compute but you
didn't show me you didn't show me okay
so there had to be some valid working
whether its conversion a polar form or
de- theorem or the evaluation of the
trig functions as long as you had some
of those you didn't need every single
one but you need a couple to show that
you actually computing something okay
part three if you realize the
denominator then I handed that to you
but you can't just state the conjugate
that's not enough I'm testing your
ability to realize not just identify
right so there's an actual skill vs I
know what something is okay doing rather
than identifying and then you've got
your simplified expression there and you
did need to simplify it Part B okay
quick note a few of you were a little
too clever for yourselves and thought ah
I know a shortcut the complex conjugate
root theorems so awesome for finding
roots cuts out half the work on one
condition when can use the conjugate
complex 100 when when the coefficients
are real and I know there's a 1 there's
a negative 2 there's a negative 7 but I
unfortunately know nothing about lambda
right and he can be complex are you
didn't I mean it turned out it wasn't
but you didn't know that right so that's
why you can't and that's why I hope you
went through I know my class we went
through the derivation of the complex
hundred route through it's like four
lines right but the mechanism depends on
the fact that the coefficients are real
if it doesn't then you can't use it um
you had to use the factor theorem and
make some step in simplify the complex
numbers so this slide here oops what's
happened to my pencil hi I frozen no
there we go um this line here which was
basically binomial there was a mark
later on for your use of binomial
theorem in the complex context so you
didn't get a mark just for staying that
you actually have to put some complex
numbers together and simplify oh you
didn't have to get to the end for the
first mark but you had to at least you
at least do something like this
okay okay Patsy Patsy against some
geometry I suppose it didn't surprise me
if you did poorly on the vector geometry
question in vector complex number
question in modern twist this was all so
poorly done draw your self a diagram
drawer yourself a diagram I know you've
got one there draw yourself a diagram
because you'll understand what's going
on much better if you do you have to
show some kind of geometric reasoning
here cuz it's two marks right and then
you had to find the complex number I
didn't think it was helpful if you did
mention something about yeah I know what
a free vector is or in a position fact
it wasn't required but it showed me yeah
you know what you're doing and you know
how these complex numbers relate to each
other when you get to part two remember
I said draw the diagram this is where a
lot of people fall down because they
didn't draw a diagram so their rotation
was just all wrong maybe they rotated
the square about its own center instead
of about about oh and so they came up
with a completely different method for
working out where the complex numbers
were which wasn't valid with this
because the rotation was about a
different point okay there was the first
mark for recognizing yeah okay I know
that I should multiply by a complex
number to achieve that rotation and then
the final mark was for just getting your
expression for B dash yes okay if if you
can't get the first part obviously it's
this only on the paper I would move on
and I would come back you can make
assumptions you can say for instance
suppose I'm doing I'm doing this line of
working here right and I know I get
something out here that I like no no
that's not right ok but if I work from
that from that point I can still garness
and marks later on if I've got it
completely wrong okay if what I'm
demonstrating your part 3 & 4 still is
valid and hasn't simplified the question
okay
if you stopped that's not necessarily a
bad thing like that's an exam technique
maybe probably the time you ended up
saving you can use on the end of the
paper if you get nothing and say oh I
suddenly have 15 minutes at the end of
the paper because I can't do that much
of the paper and um I want to do
something you can actually you can say
things like right um for say for the
next part which depends on this right I
could say assuming B dash equals and you
know you could at least make a guess you
can make something reason suppose you
know you might say our route to Zeb
thats completely wrong okay but at least
I can go with a value and then I can do
some things next and I can get to get to
Mars if you're in that unusual situation
where it's like I have nothing else to
do except for try something you've got
nothing to lose so that's that's
something you can do part 3 not much to
say on that one you just had to make
some reference to the vector 0 V dash
and you pretty much there and part 4 was
actually really well done for those
people who got there I was pleased with
that I'm seeing the marks there was a
geometric reason to get Ian how it
relates to everything else again the
diagram was tremendous help and you can
see back on mine it's plain as day where
he has to be right like you get this
tremendous advantage of the fact that
it's a square you know what you can draw
a decent square and you can work out
where that is I know with the other
conic sections that's harder to do but
for this one there was no excuse okay